it was cold that winter evening as I
amble down my quiet street I needed a
walk to clear my mind of all the clutter
and stress of the season it seems that
every year it gets worse
more obligatory parties irritated
drivers and panicky shoppers long lines
everywhere I remember a time when I was
more expectant when the reason for all
the celebrating meant everything to me
but sadly this night my internal
monologue was let's just get this thing
over and get back to normal
frankly my cynicism troubled me and when
I'm troubled I take a walk even if it's
near midnight even if it's cold even if
there are still things to be done the
hour was late and a light rain was
falling stray flakes of snow torold and
mingled in from windows and trees the
lights of the season Sparkle through the
heavy mist like stars aching to being
brightly on this dreary dark night
turning up my collar I pulled my jacket
tighter that kind of coal finds its way
through most any opening as I walked I
saw them out of the corner of my eye
Mary Joseph the baby Jesus displayed in
a wooden stable in someone's front yard
the usual characters were assembled as
well Shepherds sheep camel the wise men
three on the stables roof precariously
perched angel looked on and was tilting
slightly to the left all of them were
illuminated by two bright floodlights
shining from the grass in front of them
I almost passed them by they were easy
to miss as I've grown accustomed to
their presence they are after all
available everywhere in all sizes
ornaments eyes mantel sized coffee table
size and yard size
they come in a box easy to assemble but
that night and I'm not sure why
something caused me to turn my head
inviting me to linger I stopped to look
at them for a while as one would stand
in front of a Rembrandt painting in a
museum I must admit it felt somewhat odd
and awkward after all grown-ups don't
pause and stare at yard manger scenes
but for some reason that night that
moment I felt I should be there to
witness something to see I folded my
arms and I look to beat into this
mysterious nudge she wore blue Mary
always wears blue a neatly pressed blue
garment her face porcelain and
untouchable had a fixed expression
pleasant and peaceful with her fragile
hands folded in prayer she gazed down
adoringly at her child she was perfect
this mary pristine with moisture
glistening on her smooth ceramic shawl
Joseph wore brown Joseph always wears
brown brown is a fitting color for a
character relegated to the background
for someone who never gets top billing
his eyes appeared vacant and his beard
was neatly trimmed he was there as he
always is on the edges he can't seem to
find his place everyone has something
distinctive wings crowns gifts halos a
shepherd's crook but all he has is brown
then there was the baby Jesus his tiny
arms extended the star attraction a halo
encircled his little head reaching from
ear to ear a clean white fabric wrapped
around him swaddled I supposed as the
appropriate Christmas word to use
he smiled an unearthly smile
he's always happy this manger Jesus it
looked like he'd never slept and never
cried it didn't appear that he wanted to
be held nursed or cuddled either I won't
take the time to describe the others but
you know them well you probably even
know where each is positioned at the
stable the shepherds go there the camels
and sheep there
the wise men there there and there I
imagine you too our custom to their
presence now remain standing trying to
stay warm looking at them through the
Gaza mist I pondered I simply couldn't
relate to them in any way they seemed
remote and untouchable just like this
season had become for me with
considerable guilt I wondered why don't
I like these people
after this abrupt and irreverent thought
came to me I half expected the ground
underneath to open up and swallow me
whole or bolt of lightning to descend
with a flash and a snap leaving a little
pile of smoldering ashes that used to be
me I closed my eyes and waited for the
end thankfully neither the heavens nor
the ground opened so I continued my gaze
and then something happened something I
frankly don't expect you to believe I
heard a noise coming from Mary's
direction it startled me
who's that I said though her figure
didn't move a soft voice pleaded this is
not me she cried this is not real and
her voice broke please listen to me my
garment it isn't this clean and it's not
this brilliant shade of blue it's a blue
faded by the dust of a long journey to
Bethlehem it smells of my sweat and of
the mule whose back I wrote upon my blue
is stained with red the blood of birth
it's soiled by the dung of a stable
floor in my face my real face is
blemished I'm a teenage girl
my brow is furrowed from a worry worried
about this baby about tomorrow what will
Herod do will he find us in my eyes my
eyes are red from tears of pain I'm so
lonely and afraid this is my first baby
and my mother is not here with me this
is not who I am she said again I'm real
please let me be real and her voice
trailed off
her words both gentle and moving reach
down inside of me so deeply I could
barely breathe and while I was catching
my breath I heard a deeper voice you
were wrong about me too it was coming
from Joseph's direction this is not me
this is not real please listen to me he
said firmly I started to take a step
backwards but his voice riveted me in
place listen he repeated really listen I
am NOT the quiet simple character you
make me out to be my eyes are not vacant
hours ago they were full of fire when I
grabbed the innkeeper's tunic with a
tight grip and said don't you tell me
there is not some room somewhere and he
found a place for us I'm a man with a
purpose to travel where I was told to go
and to lead my family safely there and
we made it and now that we are here I am
still on guard for in danger Joseph
continued yes I wear brown but it is for
stealth I blend in with my surroundings
and from my vantage point my eyes scan
every opening in this place for anyone
who is out to do his harm and no one
will get by me let them try I am the
keeper of this light and I will keep him
safe you're wrong about me
this is not who I am I am real please
let me be real his words soaked into me
like the evenings mist
I felt admonished and awakened to
something that was true and then I heard
a cry
I looked at Jesus in the wooden manger
he was thrashing about in the hay
he had soiled himself and he looked
uncomfortable his cloth was twisted in
his arms and legs he grimaced from the
prickly straw his face was red and his
cry grew louder the cry of a hungry
infant his toothless mouth opened and he
arched his back he cried so hard he ran
out of breath and for a moment it was
quiet but I knew it was that quiet
before he drew another breath and then
he wailed so loudly I expected the
lights in the nearby houses to turn on
and the neighbors to come running out I
wondered if he too would speak but he
didn't need to somehow his words were in
me and I spoke for him this is not me
this is not real please listen to me
the reason I came the reason I was sent
was to be real to feel everything you
felt to know everything you need because
I needed it to to hurt like you hurt to
cry like you've cried laugh like you've
left skinned my knee like you've skinned
your knee and have my heart broken like
your heart has been
I came so that one day or one winter
night when you come face to face with
your defeat your moment of absolutely
need you can come to me and say you know
this to be with me and lead me through
it and I will
this is not me
I'm real pleased
then there was silence along stillness
that hushed the wind and pushed away the
noises of the night in the quiet I was
being given room room to feel and
consider what I've just seen in her
and out of the silence the truth
appeared like stars revealed by parting
clowns
maybe the figures before me weren't real
because I had made them that way so they
would be predictable and safe easy to
ignore and boxed up after Christmas out
of sight and out of mind
maybe if Jesus wasn't real he would be
tame and small maybe I had rendered him
untouchable because I was afraid of his
touch I'm sorry I said I know this isn't
you I can see it now you're not who I've
seen you to be untouchable and perfect
something I made rather than someone who
made me you are real you're true and you
were here I am so sorry I said again as
my eyes brimmed with tears the sorrow
nudged me to kneel next to Shepherd on
the wet grass in front of something so
real so very real I couldn't even begin
to comprehend it as I knelt I became a
part of the story and the story became a
part of me and I felt his gentle pardon
suddenly everything expanded the scene
this night
and I felt real
after a while I stood and remained there
quietly looking at them as they gazed
back at me and I realized something I
liked these people now and I think they
like me shivering I wondered if Jesus
was cold too so I laid my scarf over his
hands and his feet the same hands and
feet I would one day see again I tucked
him in as best I could
good night I said to him sleep well
you've traveled far
I stayed beside him for a few minutes
just as I once stayed beside my own
newborn sons as they drifted into sleep
then a low regal voice came from one of
the wise men he whispered as if he was
aware Jesus was sleeping
we like you were drawn to this place and
have journeyed far to come here to see
what you have seen and what you have
seen is what this world has been waiting
for and from a shepherd standing behind
Joseph I heard another quiet voice once
you hear the angels sing you will never
be the same
if you listen carefully there always
and then there was quiet no more voices
no more movement no more surprises
I sensed it was time to go I started the
walk back to my house the cold wind and
a few flakes of snow urged me along my
pace was slow and thoughtful this walk
had become a journey I didn't want to
end something had returned to me and I
yearned for it to remain when I reached
the corner of the street I thought I
heard singing in turn for one last look
in the distance I saw a warm glow coming
from a small wooden stable in a yard
down the street sheltering something
inside there was older than the Stars
and bigger than our whole wide world and
it was real
you